in this video you're going to learn how
to find reference angles so we're going
to talk about what exactly is a
reference angle and how to find it in
both radians as well as in degrees so
let's dive into this video first of all
what exactly is a reference angle well
you probably learned how to draw angles
in standard position but if not what you
do is you start by drawing your initial
Ray this is like where it initiates or
starts it's like a spinner you take that
spinner and if you spin it this
direction
counterclockwise we say that's a
positive angle if you spin it this
direction
that's clockwise we say that's a
negative angle and just like a spinner
eventually it's going to stop or
terminate so say for example it
terminates or stops right here
this is what we call our angle of
rotation but where the reference angle
comes in is wherever that angle stops
okay that terminal Ray stops you want to
drop a perpendicular to the x-axis and
your reference angle is going to be the
angle that's in between the terminal Ray
where it terminates or stops and the
x-axis it's going to be an angle between
0 and 90 degrees if you're in degrees or
0 and pi over 2 if you're in radians now
if you were to let's say stop somewhere
over here you'd want to drop the
perpendicular like this to the x-axis
and here would be your reference angle
if you ended up over here in the fourth
quadrant you're going to want to drop
your angle to the x-axis here's your
reference angle if you're just in the
first quadrant you drop it to the x-axis
and there's your reference angle so
again that reference angle is always
going to be between 0 and 90 or 0 and pi
over 2 if you're in radians now some
students they like to have a little
formula to help them along and you can
certainly do that you can say well if
I'm in the second quadrant I just take
Pi which is like 180 degrees minus the
angle and that's going to give me the
reference angle if you're in the third
quadrant you take the angle Theta minus
Pi which remember Pi is 180 and that's
going to give you your reference angle
if you're in the fourth quadrant you do
2 pi minus Theta that gives you a
reference angle and if you're just in
the first quadrant it's just going to be
Theta your angle so let's look at some
examples here and I'll show you how this
works
so say for example 7 pi over 6. first
thing you want to do is figure out where
is 7 pi over 6. well we're going to
start over here along our positive x
axis
and when it's an improper fraction like
this what I like to do is convert it
into a mixed number so I would say 6
goes into 7 once
with one left over so this is really
like 1 and 1 6 Pi so remember Pi is like
180 degrees
and then we go another 1 6 of Pi so this
would be like 2 pi but we're going to go
1 6 of the way
and that's our terminal Ray right there
then what we do is we always want to
drop a perpendicular to the x-axis never
to the y-axis and we ask ourselves
what's that reference angle well in this
case you can see we went 1 Pi also
another 1 6 of Pi so it's going to be 1
6 Pi or you can say pi over 6 because
that's like understood to be a one in
front of that Pi there and that's your
reference angle
now you might be saying Mario why do
they even call it a reference angle well
you could think of this as referring
back to
an angle in the first quadrant with a
central angle of pi over 6 these two
triangles are going to be congruent to
one another which means that the
uh side lengths are going to be the same
so we can use it to help us to find the
values of trig functions of common
angles and we'll talk about that when we
get into the unit circle I'll put a link
at the end of this video directing to
one of my unit circle videos but for
right now we're talking about how do we
find that reference angle so let's look
at number two 312 degrees so this one
what I would do is I would start along
the positive x axis that's what we call
our initial array where it initiates or
starts it's a positive angle so we're
going to go counterclockwise and 312
let's see that's going to take us to 90
180 270 plus another 42 degrees so right
about there approximately
and then we're going to drop a
perpendicular to the x-axis okay a right
angle whatever that Angle now is in
between this terminal Ray and the x-axis
that's going to be our reference angle
and you can see it's going to take
another 48 degrees
to get to that x-axis so that's going to
be our reference angle
okay for number three now another radian
one we have 25 pi over 4. what's the
reference angle on that one
well again notice we have an improper
fraction so I would say 4 goes into 25
six whole times with one left over so
that's 6 and 1 4 Pi remember Pi is 180
so we start over here along the positive
x-axis we go 180 or Pi then we go 2 pi 3
Pi 4 Pi 5 Pi 6 Pi this would put us at 7
Pi but we're just going 1 4 of Pi so
like a quarter of the way
that's our terminal Ray now remember
wherever we end up it doesn't matter how
many times we go around or what
direction wherever we end up we always
want to drop a perpendicular to our
x-axis and then we look at that
reference angle that angle in between
the terminal Ray and the x-axis in this
case you can see it's going to be 1 4 Pi
which you can write as pi over 4. this
is understood to be a one in front so 1
pi over four remember it's always
positive and it's always between 0 and
pi over 2 if you're in radians or 0 and
90 if you're degrees so let's look at a
number four now what do you think for
this one 100 degrees
so if I was going to do this problem I
would start over here along the positive
x-axis I would rotate 90 degrees which
is a right angle plus 10 more degrees
would bring us to 100 degrees
show the direction that we're traveling
here and then wherever you end up you
want to drop a perpendicular to the
x-axis and you look at that angle
between the terminal Ray and the x-axis
and that's our reference angle in this
case you can see it's going to take us
80 degrees more to get to that x-axis so
80 degrees is going to be our reference
angle and you got it so the next step is
to use these reference angles to help us
to find the values of trig functions at
multiples of 30 45 60 or in degrees
would be pi over 3 and pi over 4 and pi
over 6 those ones so let's go ahead and
follow me to that video right there
mastering the unit circle and we'll get
some more practice I'll see you over
there